there are 170 deer on a reservation
the deer population is increasing at a
rate of 30 percent per year
write a function that gives the deer
population p of t on the reservation t
years from now
all right let's think about this and
like always pause this video and see if
you can work it out on your own but
let's think about what p of 0 is
p of 0 this is going to be the initial
population of deer the population at
time zero well we know that that's going
to be the 170 deer that we start on the
reservation
now let's think about what p of one is
what's going to be the population after
one year
what's going to be our original
population 170 but that it increases at
a rate of 30 percent per year so it's
going to be 170 plus another 30 percent
of 170. so i could write that as 30
times 170
or i could write this as 170 plus 0.3
times 170 30 percent as a decimal is the
same thing as 30 hundredths or 3 tenths
or i could write this as if i factor out
a 170 i would get 170
times
1 plus
0.3 which is the same thing as 170 times
1.0
and this is a really good thing to take
a hard look at because you'll see it a
lot when we're growing by a certain rate
when we're dealing with what turns out
to be exponential functions
when we if we are growing
well i almost made a mistake there it's
1.3
almost
so here you go 1.3 1 plus 0.3 is 1.3 so
once again take a hard look at this
right over here because it's going to be
something that you see a lot with
exponential functions
when you grow by thirty percent that
means you keep your hundred percent that
you had before and then you add another
thirty percent and so you would multiply
your original quantity by one hundred
and thirty percent and one hundred
thirty percent is the same thing as one
point three so if you are growing by
thirty percent you are growing by three
tenths you would multiply your initial
quantity by 1.3
so let's use that idea to keep going so
what is the population after two years
well you'd start that second year with
the population at the end of one year so
it's going to be that
170 times 1.3
and then over that year you're going to
grow by another 30 percent so if you're
going to grow by another 30 percent
that's equivalent to multiplying by 1.3
again
or you could say that this is equal to
170 times 1.3
to the second power
and so i think you see where this is
going if we wanted to write a general p
of t
so
if we just want to write a general p of
t it's going to be whatever we started
with
and we're going to multiply that by 1.3
however many times however many years
have gone by
so to the t power because for every year
we grow by 30 percent which is
equivalent mathematically to multiplying
by 1.3 so after a hundred years it would
be 170 times 1.3 to the 100th power